اقامه حزام امني من الغرب الى الشرق على
طول الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا لابقاء الحدود
امنه هدف انقره التي تسن سلسله غارات جويه
على شمال شرق سوريا ومواقع لمقاتلين اكراد
يقول الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
المنطقه الامنه ستسمل بحكم الامر الواقع
مدينه كوباني او عين العرب التي انزعتها
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في العام 2015 من
تنظيم داعش بدعم من الولايات المتحده
الامر الذي ردت عليه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في حديثا للعربيه مؤكده ان
المنطقه الامنه هي امنه فقط لتنظيم داعش
بدعم تركي تركيه هي لم تكن موثوقه بالنسبه
لتحالف الدولي منذ عام 2014 بسبب علاقتها
الواضحه مع تنظيم داعش الارهابيه نحن
شاهدنا والعالم مشاهده
البوابات
وجرابلس واعزاز مفتوحه بين داعش دوله
تركيا
التي تنوي انقر القيام بها اكدتها اسد
مشدده على انها بكامل جهوزيتها لصديق اي
هجوم بري والدفاع عن المنطقه وسكانها
واشنطن جددت معارضتها الشديده لسن تركيا
عمليه
تلوح بها منذ ايام شمالي سوريا وطالبت
انقره بوقتها لانها تهدد امن الجنود
الامريكيين الموجودين في مواقع لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في المقابل اعربت روسيا
عن املها بعدول تركيا عن تنفيذ عملياتها
العسكريه البريه واعتبرت ان لا احد يريد
تصيد التوتر